coming  [Music]  what what I thought I heard a bit  thought William not you piss off no you  piss off William you first know you know  you you first know you piss off [ __ ]  what no I just I can't hear you not you  piss off William walls jinx you owe me a  grog  [Music]  [Music]  what are you doing huh  oh I'm I'm producing now what huh  what's he doing here uh I'm uh I'm  replacing Jared now no you're not  [Music]  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  let's give Ayesha a little bit of a  black eye I think that's her next step  Mohammed of course did strike Asia but  only lightly causing her great pain  [Music]  Kailash you [ __ ] oh yeah  [Music]  you just call the press is United States  [Music]  [Music]  you